we have all felt the impact of climate
change all summer from those
record-breaking wildfires to the
catastrophic flooding and deadly heat
waves a recent u.n report on global
warming says this humans must
drastically cut the amount of carbon
dioxide released into the air or
there will be even more dangers in
decades to come
ben tracy is in iceland where one
potential solution is starting
operations he'll explain exactly what
that means because he got an up close
look first on cbs mornings ben good
morning to you
gail good morning from iceland of course
this country is known for its amazing
landscapes but we actually came here to
see all of this these things that look
like giant air conditioning units
they're going to get turned on later
today they will actually suck carbon
dioxide out of the air so it doesn't
heat up the atmosphere the reason for
this is scientists say we are at a point
now where we don't just need to reduce
our emissions we also need to reverse
them
we need all solutions and all approaches
here in iceland history is about to be
made the world's first large-scale
attempt to directly capture carbon
dioxide and bury it underground
this are the collector containers so
that's exactly where the air comes in
julie gosalvez is an executive with the
swiss company climb works today it will
start operating these 96 fans powered by
a nearby geothermal plant as soon as the
fans are on
every tons of co2 that's removed is a
ton that's actually helping fighting
climate change and not contributing to
global warming but i have to say this is
smaller than i thought it would be is
that a good thing or a bad thing well
this is actually a very good thing this
is compact and can capture and install a
lot of co2 the carbon dioxide first gets
drawn into these collectors and then
sand here comes in here
processed in this room and mixed with
water
inside this domed building it gets
injected into the ground it's trapped in
two stones how long does it stay there
more than a thousand years so how much
carbon dioxide is this thing gonna suck
out of the air every year yeah so the
capacity of this plant is four thousand
tons that's a drop in the carbon dioxide
ocean nearly 40 billion tons of co2 are
now released in the atmosphere every
year much of it from fossil fuels
eliminating those emissions means
abandoning gas powered vehicles
finding new fuels to power airplanes new
materials to build buildings and getting
all of our electricity from renewable
sources scientists say carbon capture if
dramatically scaled up could help buy
time climbworks has big investors
including microsoft which is also paying
to offset its own emissions
we do believe that those companies that
have more should do more lucas joppa is
microsoft's chief environmental officer
is this in some way just kind of letting
you off the hook knowing that you can
spend money to offset your emissions i
don't believe so there's no credible
economic model that shows the world
achieving a net zero carbon economy by
2050 which is what the world must do
without carbon removal playing a
significant role in that equation a
canadian company is planning to build
this carbon removal plant in west texas
which it says will remove about a
million tons of co2 a year
united airlines is a major investor but
skeptics like climate scientist zeke
house father say carbon removal is still
too expensive and complicated to
replicate worldwide and we certainly
should not see it as an alternative to
cutting our emissions when we can so
there's no magic bullet for climate
change there's only magic buckshot it's
thousands of different solutions working
together that's going to solve the
problem
and the folks here in iceland agree they
say this is not a magic bullet but if
you could build enough of these all over
the world it can be part of the solution
and that begins later today when they
turn these things on nate
just like president biden said this week
the climate change crisis is our problem
ben tracy in iceland thank you